thanks for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show glad you're here
the way we teach things on this show the
way we teach things in our classes the
way we teach things when I speak across
America the way we teach things and
whatever we do are based on a series of
principles because we have discovered
that after going broke and losing
everything it made me stop that was 25
years ago it made me stop and look at
what conventional wisdom says and I've
decided conventional wisdom is an
oxymoron conventional wisdom makes
people typical average mediocre and
morons I don't want to be conventional
in anything I want to be typical or
average or mediocre in anything if
normal is good then that's okay let's be
normal but normals not good normal in
America today is 70 percent of Americans
are living paycheck to paycheck
according the Wall Street Journal normal
in America today is bankruptcies
increase almost every single year normal
in America today is people work their
whole lives and retire and say I sure
hope the government which is well known
for its ability to handle money will
take care of me normal in America today
is the number one cause of divorce in
North America is your number one cause
of divorce as money fights and money
problems normal in America today is a
stupid but belief you can't be a student
without a student loan normal America
today is carrying some many credit cards
in your hip pocket that it throws your
back out of whack and you have to see a
chiropractor normal American today is a
car with a payment and no idea that I'm
ever going to live without a car payment
normal American today is I'm going to
buy as much house as I can buy as soon
as I can buy it regardless of how broke
I am and then can't figure out why I'm
broken why this house is a curse to me
normal in America today is broke and it
sucks looking good and no freaking money
big hat no cattle that's normal so don't
talk to me about normal normal sucks I
don't want to be normal I don't want you
to be normal
and if you ask me questions about how
you can be more normal you're not going
to like the answers normal does not work
it's not working and continuing to do
the same thing over and over again and
expecting a different a different result
is the definition of insanity the
12-steppers saying they're right that's
stupid
if you keep doing what you've been doing
you're gonna keep getting what you've
been getting you don't like where you
are you need to change the recipe that
is your life you got to change what
you're doing I'm so stupid I started
with nothing and I became a millionaire
by the time I was 26 years old I did it
all on borrowed money that's how dumb I
am I had a million dollar net worth but
I was still broke how dumb is that the
banks got sold to another bank they
called the notes and spent the next two
and a half years of my life losing
everything I owned I was 26 year old
years old I made $250,000 that year 27
years old I made $6,000 cash taxable
income been there done that got the
t-shirt I know what stupid looks like up
close and personal I've seen him in my
mirror I know what stupid looks like I
know what it feels like to be so scared
you can't breathe Sharon would have left
me but she didn't have the money she had
no way to leave really I understand I
get it and when that happened to me I
learned that all the stuff you're told
by about half the financial planning
community is ridiculous and stupid the
stuff you're told by Money Magazine is
ridiculous and stupid have you ever had
have you ever heard a soul that said I
read money magazine and it changed my
life
seriously typical conventional boring
Vennela normal financial advice sucks
because it creates typical conventional
normal people it's not working
you're just kind of radical and you're
out there on the edge no I'm just not
normal if you want to call that radical
you can call it but normal sucks who
wants to be normal I figured out that
the Bible says the borrower is slave to
the lender God is smart smarter than you
and if you don't believe he's there he's
way smarter than you
God is smart the borrower is slave to
the lender in the house of the wise our
stores of choice food and oil a foolish
man devours all he has save money stay
out of debt
don't spend everything you make God
loves a cheerful Giver always be
generous with your giving have a plan
Jesus said don't build a tower without
first counting the cost lest you get
halfway up and you're unable to finish
and all who see you begin to mock you
and say there's another normal person as
you're living without a plan you'd never
build a house without a blueprint and
you go through four or five or ten
million dollars worth of income in your
lifetime and never write it down once
that's the definition of stupid that's
what I was doing it's how I was living
and if you're living that way you're
stupid - stupid people do not win at
life and money until they learn how to
have quality relationships learn how to
treat other people learn how to be a
good husband a good wife a good son a
good daughter a good mom a good dad a
good employee a good employer good
people do move ahead in this world I
know you watch so much television that
you believe otherwise some of you have
lost your soul to reality TV that isn't
reality can't you tell when somebody's
reading a script are you that lame so we
these basic principles in our life we
don't borrow money we always give we
live on a written plan we don't borrow
money ever we always give a minimum as
an evangelical Christian as it is a
tithe to my local church that's my
minimum starting point always always we
always save and invest always out of
every dollar we make something is saved
and invested something is given we
always have a written plan on paper on
purpose before the month begins we
always realize that relationships Trump
money relationships are the only things
that are real they matter we're not
transactional and it's more important to
be a good dad than it is to be a rich
dad it's more important to be a good mom
than it is to be a rich mom think about
how you treat people that work on your
team those of you that call yourselves
leaders and maybe you're just a boss
relationships matter we always live on
less than we make no matter what we make
we're going to live on less than that we
will adjust the lifestyle to be under
what we met and these days substantially
under what we make it would be absurd to
try to spend what we make now what has
that resulted in over 25 years of living
this way since running my life into the
wall like a NASCAR and exploding it up
into the stands what does it resulted in
to live debt-free to live on a budget to
live on this and you make to always save
to always give and to always value
quality relationships what does that
result in it's resulted in wealth and
that's the formula for wealth building
so pardon me
if I think your little credit card
points are stupid pardon me if I don't
go along with this idea that you want to
borrow money to get your education
because I don't think you should be
stupid when you're getting your
education pardon me if I think when you
lease your car it makes you look shallow
because you're defining yourself by what
you drive and you're driving something
you can't freakin afford because you
didn't pay for it
pardon me if I figured out how this
works I'm trying to get you to do it for
your sake that's why we're here people
I'm going to be all up in your business
until you change your life because I
care and I want you to win this is the
Dave Ramsey show